I feel like one of the areas that
independent people like me can can have
a little advantage over big companies is
that we can inject more personality into
our apps and we can not put up some some
facade that looks like we are a big
company we can we can do things the big
companies can't do the big companies
can't have personality
they just can't that's just not how
people come together and work by
committee that doesn't personality does
not come out of committees do you like
the idea that people identify your app
is like one guy at home made this is
Marcos app or do you prefer the idea
that people are getting overcast and
maybe even think it's made by a big
company I used to care a lot about that
I and you see a lot of a lot of
independent developers do this where
they will do things like they'll say we
and all the copy that mentions you know
the author or they'll say well this is
what we believe or you can contact us
and with overcast I decided to use drop
all that and you just say I everywhere
and to to inject some more personality
into the app because for so many years
computer software has been bland and
devoid of personality in order to be
neutral and all-inclusive and make sure
you don't offend or turnoff anybody and
there's a place for that in fact most
software should probably keep doing that
the reaction for overcast having
personality in it has been universally
very positive I did not every time I I
do something maybe I'll add some little
copy in the app like I recently added a
setting to to put the icon badge on the
icon of how many episodes you have
unplayed and the description text of
this is this adds stress to your life
and because I hate that option and
everyone could ask me to add it so I'm
like okay fine I'll add it but I'll tell
you it'll add stress to your life as I
was kind of tongue-in-cheek remark about
why you shouldn't use this setting and
and that's on a screen called nitpicky
details which is basically a collection
of settings people have badgered me into
adding to the app that I don't think are
necessary every time I do things like
this I think it's a risk and I think
maybe it'll turn off some people and
every time it's had the opposite effect
every time it people have I'll get
hundreds of tweets saying hey look at
this this is so great I'm so happy to
see personality because I think people
are kind of starved
or some kind of personality in software
which is so rarely the actual case do
you worry that if people know you an app
is made by one person they might think
it's less professional or reliable is
that say into your head it was a silly
question and that is a very valid
concern for a lot of kinds of apps I
don't think it's true of a podcast
player you know like if I was making
software for dentists or on their office
from which by the way if you've ever
seen dental office software it's wow
that could use some interface help but
you know something like that you would
want a company behind that you would
want that to seem official and
conservative and you know have resources
behind it but something like a podcast
player made for people who like podcasts
on their iPhones I don't think that
really matters that much I also think
that you know the the assumption that
big company software would be more
reliable unfortunately has proven itself
not to be the case very often recently I
think the big companies keep showing us
over and over again that they actually
might be less reliable than what
independent people are producing I was
not always good at this and and I still
often have misses and you know not
everything I do succeeds what I'm able
to do is I make things for myself and
when I step out of that I don't do very
well as long as I just keep making
things for myself those tend to do
pretty well and there are enough other
people like me not a ton but there are
enough that it can support one person
salary pretty well when you do it right
right which I know you don't always but
when you do it right what do you do
right if I knew I wouldn't have mrs.
professionally what's your problem well
I need to stop blogging what is it about
blogging that causes you stress I have a
really hard time taking the criticism
when I
it isn't just criticism a lot of it is
just like you know trolling but some of
it is legitimate criticism and I always
just feel awful about it and I don't
know whatever reason I can say whatever
I want in a podcast and get almost no
crap for it from anybody it's amazing if
I write anything on my blog you just put
under such a massively higher level of
scrutiny
that it I just get the worst responses
oh and and it takes a lot more time to
write things for a blog that's I haven't
written a lot recently and then that's
part of the reason why that I know I can
just get out my ideas in the podcast and
not only will I be able to get more out
with less effort and then it's also in a
conversational format where my friends
and the podcast will also like they'll
build on it and they'll disagree with me
and we'll have a discussion so I think
it's better for everybody and then all
of that will also then be greeted by a
much better response from people where
that I if you write on a blog you don't
get that if you write on a blog it's
it's it feels more formal and permanent
to the reader and so the reader comes
and looks at something if I say on a
podcast well I kind of think maybe this
might be the case if I write on the blog
this is the case period then that's a
very different environment and so people
there will be will attack it that's
there you didn't think about this or and
the people who are reading the blog a
lot of them are kind of like these
drive-bys that these people who don't
know me they they haven't been reading
my stuff so they don't really have the
context of who I am how I talk the kind
of person I am and what what I am
probably really thinking if I didn't say
things exactly right or in the best way
whereas in the podcast you have so much
more context of like people's humanity
you have their voice you have you hear
all their imperfections you hear them
inner discussion with other people you
you kind of feel like it's your friend
talking every time I've started a
controversy recently I've regretted
starting it I don't usually start
controversies intentionally and people
who read my stuff or probably they
probably think I'm just biessing about
that because it seems afterwards looking
back like yeah that was probably gonna
stir up some controversy but I don't
usually intend for that to happen and
it's not I don't feel good when it does
so I try to avoid that now a thanks to
old
komm for supporting this video I like to
listen to audio books inaudible when I
take the dogs for a walk and with over a
hundred and eighty thousand titles in
the audible collection I don't imagine
I'll be running out of options anytime
soon
currently on my reading list and sitting
on my phone here is Pandora's star by
Peter F Hamilton it's a science fiction
book it was recommended to me by a few
listeners via Twitter I'd rather not
give away the plot but I'm enjoying it
so far I think there's a fair chance
you'd like it to but no matter what kind
of books you're into audible is sure to
have something you like they've got a
huge collection of spoken word material
you can put it on various devices and
you can try a free one-month trial
including your first book by going to
audible.com slash computerphile
that's audible.com slash computerphile
so they'll know you came here from the
channel give them a try audible are a
great way to pass the time on your long
commutes at the gym or like me out
walking the dogs and now thanks to
audible for making extra videos like
this one possible or if I just have a
really awesome idea of something else I
want to do instead and that doesn't
happen very often most of my ideas are
terrible and I can recognize that early
on that you know what this idea that I
thought was really cool that I should
not do what I think was on paper or
storyboard a game or like what's a lot
look like at this point start typing